[Music]
meagan Markel eleven days after her
fairytale I Do's to Prince Harry well it
seems her new life as a Duchess
definitely suits her as an American who
is establishing a new life across the
pond the Duchess is getting guidance and
help adjusting to living in Great
Britain from both Amal Clooney and
Victoria Beckham apparently in-law has
helped Megan settle into UK life and
perhaps knows things that Megan doesn't
and in the same way that Victoria's sort
of taken Megan under her wing I think
mal has been quite generous in that
respect as well maybe it was on the
cover of the new issue of people which
reports that Samantha Cohen one of the
Queen's private secretaries is helping
her with protocol and the ins and outs
of raw real life Her Majesty seems to
have fully embraced her new grand
daughter-in-law here's a new photo of
the Queen meeting a dignitary and look
there's even a never-before-seen picture
of Harry and Megan on her table the
Duchess of Sussex is jumping right into
a Royal agenda which is to actively
improve the lives of others she said
earlier this year it's one of her
missions to empower women and girls for
me it's very important too
once you get the ground running even if
you're doing it quietly behind the
scenes which is what I focused my energy
on thus far is meeting with the right
people meeting with the right
organizations behind the scenes quietly
learning as much as I can that I can
maximize the opportunity we have here to
really make an impact
[Music]